don't know what you were like growing up
were you a good kid were you uh you know
well being a student were you what kind
of kid were you first of all I made
entirely out of wood a lot of people
don't know that lot of people I know you
were drafted by a humble puppet maker
correct Wow that explains your fear of
fire yeah real bad yeah uh I was a good
kid I I was I went through a pretty
shifty period though um my parents got
divorced when I was a teenager like
around 13 which is always a great time
for that yeah nothing good I'll pay 30
that's supposed to be the worst time for
a kid to experience his parents breaking
up yeah I was yeah sorry I lashed out
and uh I got expelled from high school
four times oh wait a minute
you said I was a good pretty good kid
you were a terrible kid I was good no I
was good for a while and then got
horrendous yeah and then got decent yeah
so average a bad still yeah I guess so
wait a minute were you getting expelled
for uh I got expelled for smoking weed
in school Oh in suede you know in school
ballsy yeah apparently it's frowned upon
to smoke a blunt in class
you didn't really do it in class did ya
I did
[Applause]
yeah the cops came and handcuffed me and
my oh yeah please like I went to like a
shifty school it was out of st. Paul
central in Minnesota mm-hmm oh yeah we
sweep little bit blunt and then we were
escorted out and we it was kind of it
was kind of cool because we were
handcuffed and then they walked it was
also lunch period so we got to like to
walk through everybody like yeah that's
what's up like everybody was like eating
like what's going on
but blunt yeah that's a good time if you
taste it yeah yeah
today so and then I got expelled for
pulling fire alarms to go smoke that's
terrible white waited just to have a
cigarette yeah yeah okay thought I mean
it was better than smoking in the class
yeah I was polite enough to have
everybody from the school join me yeah
and watch me do it and the local fire
department yes they came out hey thanks
for watching be sure to click Subscribe
to see even more great Conan clips you
may now return to your pirated movies
and creepy Japanese pornography